the first planes carrying aid have
landed in tonga after the pacific island
nation's main airport was cleared of
volcanic ash
these images here show the extent of the
damage from last weekend's volcanic
eruption and the following tsunami
though some phone lines have been
restored it will take weeks for the main
undersea communications cable to be
repaired ash has also contaminated fresh
drinking water on some islands entire
villages have been wiped out
a little earlier we spoke to peter
telfattafua he's an olympic athlete from
tonga based in brisbane australia
uh so i haven't i haven't uh been able
to speak to any of my family or
or friends in tonga i had there was one
message that had come through from hapai
saying that the waves had come through
but everyone was safe
but i haven't heard from never know from
my father we've been able to get through
to anybody
so aid is arriving by plane on tonga
that must be a huge relief right
yes absolutely absolutely as uh the
scale of devastation has been massive so
just knowing that aid is starting to
trickle in is is a very
uh a very positive thing
um
how has it been waiting you know to find
out what happened to your family and
friends it must have been a nightmare
it's been very difficult the waiting
process but
uh you know we
we haven't just been waiting we've been
uh
we've been working hard trying to
get the world support to let them know
that in the middle of that big volcanic
cloud there's a little island country
which is now covered in ash
so we've been working very hard we
didn't really i didn't really have the
option to uh you know to go into my room
and sit there and
and cry and wait i had to stand up and
work
so do you feel there is enough support
for for tonga international support
uh a lot of what we've been doing is
trying to get more support i
one of the challenges is that with the
communication cable down people couldn't
see the devastation
and you know i'm really
hopeful and with our outreach to the to
the world that a lot of uh a lot more
places around the world will uh will
come and help our little country
thank you very much uh peter
fartofu thank you
thank you so much